one of the fascinating things
about bitcoin
and sorry to romanticize certain notions
but satoshi nakamoto that the founder is
anonymous
maybe you can speak to whether that's
useful
but also i just like the psychology of
that to imagine that there's a human
being that was able to create something
special and walk away
uh so first are you satoshi nakamoto
i'm certain i'm not
um
no i
actually i you know i think the
provenance is really important and if i
were to look at the highlighted points i
think
having a founder that was anonymous or
sit anonymous is important i think the
founder disappearing is also important i
think that the fact that the satoshi
coins never moved is also important
i think the the lack of an initial coin
offering is also important i think the
lack of a corporate sponsor is important
i think the fact that it traded for 15
months with no commercial value
was also important
you know i i think that um
the simplicity of the protocol
and is very important i think that the
the outcome of the block size wars is
very important and all of those things
add up to
common property they're they're all in
disha indicators of a digital property
as opposed to security
if there was a satoshi sitting around
sitting on top of
50 billion dollars worth of bitcoin it
would i don't think it would um
[ __ ]
bitcoin as property but i think it would
undermine
its digital property and i if i wanted
to undermine a crypto asset network i
would do the opposite of all those
things
i would launch one myself i would sell
25 or 50 of the general public i would
keep some of the initial i would
pre-mine some stuff or early mine it you
know and i would keep an influence on it
those are all
the opposite of what you would do in
order to create
common property
and so i see the entire story is satoshi
giving a gift
of digital property
to the human race
and disappearing
do you think it was one person do you
have ideas of who it could be i
don't care to speculate
but do you think it was one person like
it was one person
maybe in conjunction with a bunch of
others i mean it might have been a group
of people that were working together but
certainly the there's a satoshi i mean
it's just so fascinating to me that one
person could be so brave and thoughtful
or do you think a lot of his accent like
the block size wars the decision to make
a block a certain size
all the things you mentioned led up to
the characteristics that make bitcoin
property
do you think that's an accident
or it was deeply thought through
like how does this is almost like a
history of science question people tried
it they tried 40 of them right i mean i
i think there's a there's a history of
attempting to create something like this
and it was tried many many times and and
they failed for different reasons and i
think that
it's like prometheus tried to start a
fire 47 times and maybe the 48th time it
sparked
and and that's how i see this this is
the first one that sparked
and uh and it sets a road map for us and
i and i think
if you're looking for any one word to
characterize it's fair right the whole
point of the network is it's a fair
launch of fair distribution
like
yeah
i have bitcoin but i bought it
in fact i've you know at this point
we've paid four billion dollars of you
real cash to buy it if if i was sitting
on the same position and i had it for
free
then there's always this question of
did i pay you know or i bought it for a
nickel a coin or a penny a coin the
question is was it fair and and that's a
very hard question to answer
right did you acquire the bitcoin that
you own fairly
and if you roll the clock back you know
you could have bought it for a nickel or
a dime but that was when it was a
million times more likely to fail
right when the risk was greater the cost
was lower and then over time the risk
became lower and the cost became greater
and the real critical thing was to allow
the marketplace absent any powerful
interested actor
right it's almost if satoshi had held a
million coins and then stayed engaged
for 10 more years tweaking things in the
background there'd still be that
question
but what we've got is really a beautiful
thing we've got a
we've got a chain reaction in cyberspace
or an ideology spreading virally in the
world
that um
that has seasoned in a fair
ethical fashion sometimes it's a very
violent brutal fashion with all the
volatility
right and there's been a lot of you know
a lot of sound and fury along the way
you